and no one will come to see your play I
already gee I recogi so to see how they
destroy against my g 6 line it's a funny
line Wow yeah I think this is actually
what I wanted to do did forgot about it
the idea is c5c for her winning the
piece yeah it's a pretty unconventional
position but I thought it was
interesting to play let's see what he's
playing here Quincy one he wants to
check meet me and quickly quickly so
that's one thing but he also wants to
play rugby one
and five is actually interesting between
age six is a little bit too much I don't
want to play King g7 here that looks
wrong hmm Quincy one is a good move it
seems
yeah I don't know Quinn b6f six but I
wanted to make sure not to be checkmated
quickly I think this is probably a
successful task doesn't look like i'm
getting checkmated quickly so this one
or 95 is also move but now can and I'm
exposing a seven actually if I go back
he also has a creative form
actually blundering g6 yeah if you take
the 95 d 6 is gone and not good
okay it is a completely stupid move why
did I do that very very unnecessary
actually I could have played whatever
group d 7 or it's just bad just bad he
can take a dance much better maybe I
have okay to at the end actually that is
possible
94 maybe to attack b5 check I don't
don't think that this is so dangerous
for me here can even play 93 ever leave
like to see 5 it also kind of
interesting let's do it
Air Force has be continued porn so I
don't know this is that grade for him
[Music]
let's go back okay I was only thinking
about 94 okay so d5 doesn't lead to much
okay let's let's do this that's at least
a little bit simpler then let's see how
can I do this
it's probably just equal anyway
[Music]
[Music]
check
[Music]
time morning could be a bit risky yes
risky
yeah g5 and so on I'm playing this for
loss rather than anything else you might
be able to sacrifice only not for win
check you have a tick there it's going
to be drawing our heads do it wait wait
wait wait wait wait do I have some Funky
Chicken I can just about save it check
him now okay draw was check kind of what
you could exchange him game dry huh Jim
no I don't know if there was more at any
point I don't know complicated that was
a complicated game I was a good move
Quincy one I don't know about the screen
b6f six but at least it felt like I'm
not mated six that was just a stupid
move okay look tasty six what's the
refutation even oh that would have been
a shot I cannot take a mate so I believe
yeah Wow okay so that was very lucky and
this is part of the game check no I'm
okay again yeah actually maybe 93 it's
something that I did consider it was
like here I'm threatening age 62 windus
but I couldn't really believe that this
is anything substantial I cannot take
because of the other pin my pawn
structure is completely wrecked yes so I
went back here i was expecting 90 form
that didn't do it and here maybe i can
do more that looks a bit passive
probably little traders making it check
every likely that is
at the end this is actually risky what I
did giving him the bishop and I wanted
to try this try a misfit Bishop takes 26
you wince la gather the point is that
this is winning and I cannot stop the
pawn yeah it was a very risky way of
playing with night against bishop and
the bishop is stronger in this position
simply oh ok guys thanks for watching